[Música]
no no
emprendedor palabra o figura que aparece
en los medios cada vez más pero que
parece inalcanzable para la mayoría de
las personas y que pensamos cuando digo
esta palabra a quienes quiénes son los
emprendedores
en general el estereotipo del
emprendedor que nos muestran los medios
son hombres blancos estadounidenses
usualmente ligados a la tecnología desde
veis estudios mark zuckerberg parecidos
son los elegidos personas que medios se
iluminaron tuvieron una idea millonaria
le ejecutaron exitosamente pero si otras
estas personas son sobre la punta de una
esfera formado por un equipo por mucho
tiempo y especialmente un ecosistema que
los trasciende
durante muchos años en mi experiencia
como emprendedora y acompañando a otros
jóvenes emprendedores me pregunté
quiénes son los emprendedores y cómo o
de dónde surgen
descubrí que los emprendedores son
personas como cualquiera de nosotros o
así empiezan y que también empiezan con
ideas nuevas o con un cambio en las
ideas que ya existen son personas que me
prueban estas ideas que faltan y vuelven
a probar que persisten a lo largo del
proceso y que se cultivan constantemente
para que esos proyectos florezcan a la
vez que también buscan un equipo de
personas que los complementan
los emprendedores surgen con un problema
un problema que alimentan sus ideas para
innovar y crear soluciones los
emprendedores entonces juegan un rol
crítico fundamental en la economía
usando sus habilidades y su iniciativa
para resolver las las necesidades de sus
comunidades
y someter a la situación que estamos
viviendo hoy estamos viviendo ya seis
meses cuando la organización mundial de
la salud declaró al joven 19 con una
emergencia sanitaria internacional
este contexto puso el foco en las
necesidades más esenciales de las
personas el foco en las falencias del
sistema de salud del sistema económico
de la medida del apoyo social en américa
latina y el mundo
pero vemos que ciertamente ya existían
pero que con la pandemia se volvieron
urgentes y sobre todo más visibles
y si miramos hacia adelante los
indicadores demuestran que todavía queda
mucho mucho más para hacer solo por
nombrar algunos el fmi prevé que al
finalizar el año van a haber más de 30
millones de personas que habrán perdido
sus trabajos en américa latina y
especialmente en guatemala nos
encontramos con la difícil proyección de
300.000 personas más en situación de
pobreza extrema
pero hay otra callada de esta pandemia
este contexto también son visible la
resiliencia característica de nuestro
continente y de nuestras comunidades a
pesar de que hay muchísimas dificultades
está también impulsaron a muchas más
personas a crear buscar soluciones
proyectos y emprendimientos
en los últimos meses fui parte de varias
iniciativas para apoyar a emprendedores
de latinoamerica y tuve la suerte de por
ver como miles miles realmente miles de
personas de toda la región distintos
contextos y realidades sociales y
especialmente jóvenes que pusieron su
empeño su tiempo su energía para
agruparse y pensar soluciones que
mitiguen las consecuencias que kobe 19
género
y por ejemplo como la falta de
ventiladores inspiró grupos a
desarrollar ventiladores de bajo costo y
más rápida producción o ve como la
necesidad de mantener la distancia
física y suspender las clases de muchos
colegios inspiron y se desarrolló en
plataformas de educación digital entre
muchos otros proyectos y cómo se avanzó
tan rápidamente para conectar
virtualmente a médicos y pacientes de
forma virtual especialmente en pacientes
que no tenían acceso a seguro a un
seguro de salud
fue realmente increíble ver tanta
motivación y proactividad para
desarrollar soluciones en un contexto
como el como el que vimos hoy transmite
realmente una idea contagiosa veces e
involucrarse en este mundo del
emprendimiento pero lo cierto también es
que a pesar de que muchísimas personas
buscando responder estos desafíos
sociales también estas mismas personas
se encuentran con varios obstáculos que
hacen que los proyectos no salgan de la
idea o que se traben al momento de
escalar
en contexto viable se torna muy difícil
a veces o imposible incluso encarar un
proyecto de impacto
entonces es importante entender qué
factores ayudan a que estos proyectos
prosperen y eso si va a la pregunta de
finas de primero el emprendedor o el
ecosistema
si esto fuera un examen de opción
múltiple o para tornos a la actualidad
oa la virtualidad
si todo es una encuesta en las historias
de instagram la opción correcta entre
emprendedores del sistema sería ambas
necesitamos trabajar las dos en
simultáneo para permitir que se
retroalimenten entre sí y realmente
impacten al desarrollo del país
entonces hoy quiero compartirles 5
factores que ayudan a que ambas
prosperen
no son los únicos factores pero son
factores fundamentales empezando por
concientizar pasar del emprendedor
aspiracional al emprendedor real
empezando por visibilizar a keynes
quienes están haciendo la diferencia en
nuestra comunidad personas concretas es
importante construir esa figura
unipersonal el emprendimiento no se
logra en soledad y no se logra de un día
para el otro
siempre nos cuestan alguna figura pero
detrás de ella en un equipo
interdisciplinario y resaltó el concepto
porque no todos podemos saberlo todo la
errónea percepción de que si puede
evitar que muchos comiencen este camino
tenemos que trabajar en conjunto unir
esfuerzos con distintos distintas
personas distintos sectores de la
sociedad pero sobre todo hay que tener
paciencia pensar
pensando en una idea es fundamental para
emprender pero el éxito depende de su
ejecución
y eso lleva a un segundo segundo factor
sobre educar y aprender uno puede nacer
con una personalidad apasionada
resiliente y proactiva todas todas estas
cualidades que ayudan a emprender pero
no seas emprendedor y menos como
emprendedor exitoso esto es un proceso
que se cultiva con el tiempo y sobre
todo en el conocimiento piénselo como un
músculo que cuando más se ejercita
mejores resultados tiene por eso es
importante que las currículas estén
pensadas y creadas para aprender a
emprender independientemente de la
disciplina que uno persiga pero también
es importante cultivar este músculo
emprendedor
no solamente a través de la educación
formal sino otra vez sino también a
través de el trabajo
y se hacen proyectos propios como los
propios y está comprobado de la práctica
y la experiencia lleva a mejores
resultados
un tercer factor es socializar la
diversidad es una de las mejores salidas
de la innovación
si quieres emprender lo mejor es salir y
conocer a personas con contextos y
conocimientos distintos al de uno con el
que uno se pueda complementar y si en tu
ciudad no existen estos espacios de
interacción uno puede aprovechar las
redes que ya existían y ahora están
creándose o expandiéndose
respondiendo también a la pandemia
importante es realmente conectarse con
gente y potenciar en sus esfuerzos
en cuanto factores sobre creado
infraestructura no hay que salir afuera
de la región para encontrar sistemas que
tengan la infraestructura legal e
impositiva que fomenta el emprendimiento
por ejemplo en chile uno puede crear la
empresa en un solo día además en muchos
países de latinoamérica se cuentan con
impulsos desde lo impositivo para eso la
emprendedora
a dar ese primer paso
y por otro lado cuando también pasó de
ser un paso de ser un lujo a una
necesidad de terminando no solamente el
acceso a la información sino también las
oportunidades en las que uno pueda
acceder
al adentrarnos cada vez más en un mundo
digital es importante fortalecer el
acceso a la conectividad una necesidad
crítica para emprender y también para
hablar especialmente en un país como
guatemala donde el acceso a internet es
del 34 por ciento y eso nos deja mucho
potencial para responder
y por último vemos lo que todos podemos
contribuir desde hoy se trata de
erradicar el estigma del fracaso ustedes
piensan que es socialmente aceptado
decir por ejemplo que el año pasado
estaban construyendo una empresa y
fracaso en muchas comunidades el fracaso
tiene una carga muy pesada es una marca
que se arrastra en la trayectoria
profesional pero en otras es una muestra
de iniciativa
yo recomiendo su asumido una actitud
metodológica analizada las causas del
fracaso para aprender de la experiencia
y lograr mejores resultados un fracaso
en este contexto se convierte en la
generación de evidencia que nos permite
identificar y aprender tenemos enfoques
en un ciclo más corto y de forma más
experimental así que hay que pasar
rápido y avanzar porque el que no
arriesga no gana
estos cinco puntos se vuelven cada vez
más necesarios en un contexto de
pandemia y con el foco en resolver
problemáticas de la línea de la
adolescencia y de la juventud porque
ciertamente es que es en contexto de
crisis más que ningún otro contexto que
nos llevan a pensar soluciones o
respuestas innovadoras que terminan
empujando a las comunidades al progreso
necesitamos entonces emprendedores que
desarrollen y generen nuevas ideas
productos o servicios pero también
necesitamos de todo para facilitar este
ecosistema de innovación porque ya sea
el lugar en el que estemos dentro de la
sociedad todos realmente podemos
contribuir
y es por eso que los invito a dar este
primer paso y empezar por re imaginar el
ecosistema emprendedor para guatemala
latinoamérica para que sea un país y una
región que se puede definir por su tasa
de emprendedores con la mira en el
progreso de las comunidades para
construir un futuro mejor para los niños
para los adolescentes y para los jóvenes
creo que así vamos a conseguir
mejores resultados así que muchas
gracias por escuchar